AND THAT'S A FOCUS OF MY ANGLE,
PART TWO.
DO YOU EVEN REMEMBER THIS GUY?
EDWIN McMULLEN WAS THE
NEVER TRUMPER'S LAST HAIL MARY
CANDIDATE.
REMEMBER HE GOT GOBS OF MEDIA
ATTENTION DESPITE THE FACT THAT
HE NEVER STOOD A CHANCE OF
DEFEATING TRUMP BACK IN THE
SPRING OF 2016?
WELL, FOR 2020 THEY FOUND A NEW
SAVIOR.
RADIO HOST JOE WALSH.
>> I'M GOING TO HIT
DONALD TRUMP, I'M GOING TO PUNCH
HIM IN THE FACE EVERY SINGLE
DAY.
I'M RUNNING BECAUSE HE'S UNFIT.
SOMEBODY NEEDS TO STEP UP AND
THERE NEEDS TO BE AN
ALTERNATIVE.
>> Laura: WHAT AN INSPIRING
MESSAGE.
THAT'S RIGHT.
FORMER ILLINOIS CONGRESSMAN JOE
WALSH IS WHO THE NEVER TRUMPER
MOVEMENT, IF YOU CAN CALL IT
THAT, HAS BEEN WAITING FOR.
AS LONG AS YOU IGNORE THAT HE
CALLED OBAMA A MUSLIM, USED THE
N-WORD ON TWITTER AND MAY HAVE
OWED HIS WIFE A MERE $117,000 IN
CHILD SUPPORT.
BUT DON'T WORRY, WALSH IS
SELF-AWARE.
OR IS HE?
>> I WOULDN'T CALL MYSELF A
RACIST.
BUT I HAVE SAID RACIST STUFF ON
TWITTER, NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
>> Laura: BUT NONE OF THAT
MATTERS.
THEY ARE STILL DESPERATELY
HYPING THE IMPOSSIBLE.
AND, COULD THEY WEAKEN HIM GOING
INTO THE FALL?
CERTAINLY.
>> NO MATTER HOW SMALL THEY ARE,
IT BECOMES A REAL IRRITANT AND A
PROBLEM.
NO INCUMBENT WANTS TO HAVE THAT.
>> Laura: COULD LOLLIPOPS GROW
ON TREES?
NONE OF YOU -- THAT'S THEY SAID
AT 88%.
TELLING "THE NEW YORK TIMES," HE
HAS A DIFFERENT APPEAL THAN BILL
WELLS.
THEY SPEAK TO THE PRIMARY VOTERS
THAT NEVER TRUMPERS LIKE ME
DON'T HAVE.
HEY BILL, YOU PROBABLY WOULD
HAVE A BETTER SHOT WITH THIS JOE
WALSH FROM THE EAGLES.
NOW WITH ALL THE HYPE, THEY ARE
SHOWING HOW SELF-SERVING THE
NEVER TRUMPERS ARE.
THESE FOLKS ARE WILLING THEIR
OWN COUNTRY TO SAY, I TOLD YOU
SO.
SO THEY LOSE A SUPREME COURT,
ALL THE FEDERAL COURTS AND THE
ECONOMY GRADUALLY IN UPPERHAND,
THEY LOSE IT ALL SO THEY CAN
HAVE THEIR LITTLE MOMENT.
AND OF COURSE, THEY WANT TO TAKE
US BACK TO WHAT, OPEN BORDERS
ET CETERA, ET CETERA.
ANTI-TRUMP GRIFTERS ARE
COMPLETELY OUT OF TOUCH WITH
REALITY.
THE ARC KIND OF LIKE THE PARTY
OF THE TOOTH FAIRY EXCEPT THERE